alors probablement probablement comme
vous et les sept milliards de personnes
sur terre
j'ai deux grands pères deux grands-pères
qu'a priori tout oppose
l'un est maçon l'autre est chirurgien
l'aï communiste l'autre plutôt droite à
l'époque au rpr
et pourtant pourtant malgré leurs
différences ils ont deux points communs
essentiels à mes yeux ils sont tous les
deux engagés pour les causes qui leur
tiennent à coeur et ils sont tous les
deux entrepreneurs alors entrepreneur
qu'est ce que ça signifie qu'est ce que
ça signifie entrepreneurs on entend
beaucoup en ce moment
littéralement entrepreneurs ça signifie
prendre entre pour moi être entrepreneur
et prendre les choses en main ça passe
par la création d'entreprise mais pas
seulement est entrepreneur c'est aussi
une question de posture être
entrepreneur c'est aussi prendre ta vie
entre les mains et la notion
d'entrepreneuriat pour moi elle est
indissociable de la notion d'engagement
j'irai même plus loin c'est en
s'engageant qu'on devient entrepreneur
alors comment j'en suis arrivée à cette
conclusion
à travers mon parcours à travers mes
expériences et j'ai envie de partager
avec vous dedeclic de déclic que j'ai eu
à travers mon histoire
j'ai aussi envie de partager avec vous
deux apprentissages et de messages alors
tout a commencé quand j'avais l'âge de
deux ans
à l'âge de deux ans mes parents se sont
séparés et vous l'aurez compris j'ai
grandi dans deux milieux sociaux
différents dans deux cultures familial
très différentes et pendant longtemps
eh ben j'ai eu un peu le cul entre deux
chaises j'avais du mal à trouver mon
identité
finalement acquis j'appartenais donc
j'ai beaucoup cherché et puis c'est
passé même après mon bac où j'avais
envie d'arrêter mes études pourquoi les
continuer alors que mon grand frère lui
avait arrêté et puis ma mère m'a dit
quelque chose d'important à ce moment là
elle m'a dit ma puce oui tu vas
travailler quarante ans de ta vie alors
t'es pas encore à quelques années près
et j'ai trouvé que ça avait plein de bon
sens alors j'ai poursuivirent j'ai fait
un bts puis après une école de
management est là quand je suis arrivé
au havre pour mon école de commerce
j'ai découvert un nouveau monde
la première année comme beaucoup
d'étudiants j'ai beaucoup fait la fête
j'ai une vie sociale qui était très
développé et un taux d'alcoolémie assez
important peut-être que l'un à l'est
avec l'autre je sais pas mais finalement
pendant ses études il y avait toujours
une question en moi ok tout ça c'est
quoi le sens à tout ça en fait et moi je
suis ou et je vais où
et puis la grande question qu'est ce que
je vais faire après qu'est ce que je
vais faire après et puis un jour un jour
tout a basculé
je m'en rappelle c'était un marty on
était en cours de géopolitique
on était en train de découvrir et
d'apprendre un peu plus sur les conflits
au moyen-orient
et puis la logique de mon pote et se
tourne vers moi et me dire essayons
d'aller voir par vous même ce qui se
passe je regarde je prends la mesure de
sa question
je prends le temps de répondre
je le regarde et je lui dis oui ok on va
y aller alors on se retrouve le soir on
refait le monde autour d'une bonne
bouteille de rhum
arrivé à la moitié on a changé de
destination
elle avait fait en même temps quelques
recherches on s'est dit que l'irak
n'était pas une très bonne idée alors de
ce oui que j'ai eu à ce moment là de ce
oui ma vie a complètement changé et a
complètement basculé en fait ensemble
avec loïc ans est engagé
on a créé notre première association qui
était un peu une sorte de deux
d'entreprises sociales de conseil à des
projets en développement
alors on s'est lancé dans une dizaine de
projets injuste passionnant il y avait
par exemple la création d'un centre de
formation à l'énergie solaire
au maroc on a travaillé aussi sur
l'audit énergétique le dit pardon d'une
banque de céréales au burkina faso est
en fait de cette expérience
extraordinaire
j'en ai retiré deux grands
apprentissages le premier voulait le
connaître le premier c'est qu'est ce que
c'est bon s'engager qu'est ce que ça
fait du bien s'engager dans un projet
qu'on a vraiment et qu'on porte à coeur
moi cet engagement ça m'a permis de déjà
de rencontrer des personnes
passionnantes
je me rappelle une fois on a fait deux
mille kilomètres on a weekend pour aller
discuter avec un gars à marseille
pendant deux heures
être un peu fou à l'époque je ne sais
pas si je le referais aujourd'hui mais
on a juste rencontrer des gens
passionnants on a aussi appris
énormément de choses et moi cet
engagement que j'ai eu pendant mes
études
cela m'a permis de me réconcilier avec
mon histoire personnelle
ça m'a permis de prendre confiance en
moi et finalement je me suis rendu
compte que je n'existais pas simplement
par d'où je venais j'existe et aussi par
qui j'étais par mon engagement et parce
que j'avais envie d'être et d'accomplir
alors le deuxième apprentissage que j'ai
eu ça a été une conviction une
conviction qu'il est possible voire même
important de pouvoir concilier ses
compétences avec un sens les compétences
avec une cause qui nous touche et je me
suis rendu compte que ce que j'étais en
train d'apprendre à l'école la gestion
de projet la finance le management que
finalement tout ça ce sont des outils
c'est à dire juste des outils
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
moins la possibilité de choisir lusage
je pouvais choisir à quelle fin dans
quel sens j'avais envie de les utiliser
finalement libre à nous d'utiliser nos
compétences nos talents pour les causes
et pour le sens qui nous paraît juste
finalement libre à nous d'adapter le
monde à nos rêves plutôt que d'adapter
le rêve nos rêves au monde
il sera c'était fort à cette époque là
alors prendre mes études
j'arrive à la fin de mes études et là
j'ai dû prendre des décisions rappelé
les décisions vous avez pris vous à la
fin de vos études
il fallait déjà que je choisis ma
dernière année de spécialisation
alors j'avais envie d'être entrepreneur
j'avais le choix entre un master
entrepreneur et un master d'audit
finances naturellement j'ai choisi
l'audi de finances je me suis dit que
c'était la meilleure manière de
rentabiliser ma dernière année et puis
d'apprendre de nouvelles choses et puis
la deuxième décision je devais prendre
c'était je devais enfin répondre à la
question bon ben ok et après ça je fais
quoi
il fallait que je me lance dans la vie
professionnelle
enfin rappelé un peu ce moment là alors
il est pas évident et donc je devais
décider je devais choisir
j'avais le choix avec la sécurité
j'avais ont proposé un poste de
direction dans une petite société
d'édition de salaire était confortable
je savais où j'allais je pouvais
rembourser mon crédit que j'avais fait
pendant mes études où j'avais le choix
de l'inconnu et me lancer dans
l'aventuré entreprenariale alors à ce
moment là je me suis posé trois
questions
la première c'était ok aymeric sais quoi
qui va te donner le plus de plaisir
ou est ce que tu vas on va dire
t'éclater le plus qu'est ce qui va te
donner le plus d'énergie
la deuxième question vous a été ou est
ce que je vais apprendre le plus qu'est
ce qui va me permettre de me développer
de d'acquérir de nouvelles compétences
et la troisième question c'était celle
de ma petite voix intérieure je me suis
demandée finalement mon intuition là
c'est la petite boussole intérieure elle
me recommande quoi alors après quelques
temps de réflexion j'ai décidé de me
lancer dans l'aventuré entreprenariale
et à ce moment là présent moment la
presse je suis devenu entrepreneur de ma
vie c'est à dire que j'ai pris ma vie
entre les mains
alors j'ai continué dans
l'entrepreneuriat j'ai lancé un
incubateur pour entrepreneurs sociaux
entrepreneur sans frontières j'ai
cofondé la ruche un espace de
collaboratif pour entrepreneurs sociaux
à paris puis j'ai même commencé à lancer
un collectif de formateur s'est vite là
bas et en 2010 j'ai rejoint hanna klaus
franz pour justement aller développer
l'esprit d'entreprendre et le sens de
l'engagement auprès des jeunes et le
faire par le faire développer ses
compétences la part le faire c'est à
dire finalement permettant à des jeunes
de monter leur propre projet
d'entrepreneuriat social pendant leurs
études
finalement ce qu'on fait c'est de
reproduire des conditions pour que les
jeunes deviennent aussi entrepreneurs de
leur vie à travers leur engagement
alors vous l'aurez compris la
transmission est important pour moi et
si je vous parle et que j'ai envie de
vous transmettre un message mais pas
seulement à vous en fait je me suis
aussi marié j'ai une petite fille
j'ai une petite fille qui elle aussi va
grandir dans une diversité dans laquelle
je suis grandi et j'ai grandi aussi elle
a la chance d'avoir des grands parents
qui sont français et des grands parents
tunisiens à la chance de grandir dans
une double culture une culture
chrétienne et une culture musulmane et
peut-être diversité là c'est juste
magnifique
parce que la vie c'est un peu comme la
cuisine c'est grâce à la diversité des
ingrédients qu'on obtient le goût alors
le message que j'ai envie de transmettre
à elisa et 10 passes et le nom de la
petite fille quand elle regardera
youtube youtube est pas devenu obsolète
le jour elle regardera le message que
j'ai envie de transmettre ma fille en
est toi qui m'écoutent deux invitations
la première c'est entreprend avis prends
ta vie entre les mains pour cela
nécessite de prendre les décisions de
faire des choix et ça ça ça demande du
courage
alors pour t'aider ans et une petite
boussole intérieure là c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'intuition
à toi de trouver comment elle fonctionne
à toi de l'écouté moi le jour où j'ai
écouté mon intuition
quand j'étais étudiant avec loïc
s'ajuste transformer ma vie alors je te
souhaite d'avoir le courage de prendre
des décisions de faire tes choix de te
lancer
et puis au pire ça marche la deuxième
invitation que j'ai envie de te faire
elle est simple c'est engage-toi engage
toi
en fait quand on lit les journaux quand
on regarde la télé quand on se balade
dans la rue quand on revisite son
histoire personnelle
on a tous des causes qui nous touche qui
nous révolte qui nous indigne et je
crois que cette énergie là de la révolte
de l'indignation
on peut la transformer en une formidable
énergie de création
moi je me suis engagé d'une manière à
travers l'entrepreneuriat social
mais finalement c'est une manière parmi
plein d'autres donc à toi trouver la
tienne à toi de trouver la cause à toi
trouver l'engagement qui te nourrir à et
qui te permettra de révéler en résumé
les deux messages que j'ai envie de
transmettre entreprend avis et engage
toi
le monde a besoin de toi merci
[Applaudissements]